[Musique]
notre dame de paris la cathédrale la
plus illustre de la chrétienté avec
saint pierre de rome a eu huit cent ans
cette année sous ces voûtes vient de
retentir le tdm de berlioz première des
manifestations qui marqueront ce
huitième centenaire
[Musique]
notre dame c'est sans doute un de ses
émouvants témoignages que nous a laissé
la fois du moyen-âge mais c'est aussi
801 de l'histoire de paris et de
l'histoire de france
[Musique]
l'un des trois portails le portail de
sainte-anne évoque l'évêque maurice de
sully qui en 11 163 décida de donner à
paris une cathédrale digne d'elle dès
lors notre dame devait participé à tous
les grands événements sa construction
n'était pas terminée
quand saint-louis y apporte à la
couronne d'épinés
à
au 14ème siècle enfin achevée elle
resplendissait de tout son éclat
paris vaut bien une messe avait dit
henri iv notre dame fut donc le témoin
de sa réconciliation avec les parisiens
et dans l'île de la cité elle apparut
alors comme le symbole de la nation
réconciliée
[Musique]
le thé des hommes qui marqua le mariage
de louis xiv avec l'infante
marie-thérèse consacre à la paix
retrouvée au traité des pyrénées tandis
que le peuple de paris continué de
dérouler ses longues processions à
l'ombre des tours déjà cinq fois
centenaires 1789 notre dame qui vit la
bénédiction des drapeaux de la garde
nationale faillit bien être démolis
sauver mais détériorer il fallut 6
millions de francs alors pour la rendre
digne du sacre de napoléon
[Musique]
au milieu du 19e siècle le parvis était
encore étriqués par l'hôtel dieu et le
bâtiment des enfants trouvés les
démolitions entreprises par le baron
haussmann en quadruple r la surface et
les 40 m de la merveilleuse façade ils
retrouvèrent la majesté que nous leur
connaissons
viollet le duc enfin lui rendit sa
flèche naguère détruit la guerre de 1870
pas ça sent trop égratigné la cathédrale
et en 1918 le tdm de la victoire marque
à la fin de la première guerre mondiale
ainsi au cours des siècles le bourdon de
notre dame n'aura pas cessé de rythmer
les heures graves aux joyeuses de
l'histoire de france
[Musique]